[Applaudissements]
comment méfiante de ce genre de
production et je trouve que cette fille
là on l'a mis volontairement le tee
shirt et tout ça et je pense que ce
n'est pas du tout comme ça on ne se met
pas du tout comme ça à l'aide pour les
deux sombres et la production mais
peut-être demander mail c'est peut-être
un bio c'est comme ça nous rajoute donc
s'armer pour qu'elle le ferait si non
naturelles canada elles ont grossi le
trait pour l'allemagne et parce qu'elle
trouve pas de mec elle veut passe à la
télé là on lui dit tu vas mettre un
petit shorty et eu à faire passer pour
la [ __ ] voilà voilà la russie
insiste françois viot cacau connu
beaucoup d'aventurés il ya très
longtemps j'étais le seul mec dans un
groupe femme et je me laisserais tout
tapé
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
elle travaille et hélas respect
[Applaudissements]
s'arrêter quelques instants là dessus
parce que c'est quand même des moments
avons pas dans la vie de davy jeune
chaîne de télévision vous avez quel âge
à l'époque j'avais 21 ans vous savez
comment elle m'appelait et ça aurait de
gros tuyaux mais ce type et et pas trop
dans le journal qu'ils avaient déjà la
mèche toutes les semaines je me savais
que tout le monde et j'invite tout le
monde à télé câble sat demain à
l'appeler gros tuyaux d'ailleurs sans
plus de relance lance le hashtag gros
tuyaux jugnot est en train de se dire il
a des jours on